Esta disputa es un poco lejana en
América Latina Entonces le pido si
podemos repasar el contexto que ha
dificultado este acuerdo
lo que ha hecho difícil este acuerdo
Rosa y es un placer estar contigo y los
televidentes es el hecho de que Irlanda
del Norte está tiene una frontera
terrestre con la República de Irlanda
que es parte de la Unión Europea pero es
parte del Reino Unido y tras la salida
al Reino Unido de la Unión Europea el
problema de donde dibujar esa frontera
parecía irresoluble lo que ha logrado el
acuerdo de Windsor es de una parte
hacer guardar la apariencia de unión
entre Irlanda del Norte y el resto de
las Naciones del Reino Unido y de la
otra parte mantener el libre movimiento
de la mayor parte de los bienes que se
comercian entre el resto del Reino Unido
Irlanda del Norte y también el resto de
la Unión Europea que sigue siendo el
principal socio comercial
de las irlandes y el Reino Unido y Oscar
le preguntó entonces para lograr este
acuerdo de Windsor Cuáles han sido las
principales concesiones que han tenido
que hacer ambas partes respecto a su
posición inicial
quizás la mayor concesión que ha hecho
la Unión Europea tenga que ver con la
capacidad de una suerte de veto que se
la le ha otorgado al parlamento de
storemont y que le permitiría
inaplicar las normas nuevas que en
materia comercial dicte la Unión Europea
sí se dan una serie de condiciones muy
excepcionales es poco probable que esas
condiciones se den sin embargo ese tipo
de
digamos soberanía compartida en lo
judicial es algo novedoso y una
concesión por parte de la Unión Europea
y para terminar este análisis le
pregunto si este acuerdo puede convencer
tanto a unionistas a como a republicanos
en Irlanda del Norte Es decir para que
nos entendamos todos a los que quieren
permanecer en el Reino Unido o los que
preferirían estar Unidos a la República
de Irlanda
ahí yo iba mi siguiente punto va a ser
más difícil mantener a los unionistas
que ya han expresado su desacuerdo con
el marco de Windsor pero seguramente van
va a beneficiar a los nacionalistas ain
que ya es la fuerza política principal
en Irlanda del Norte Irlanda del Norte
va a ser la gran beneficiada de este
acuerdo en general y
el nacionalismo Irlandés en particular